le ciel le soleil et de l'air pur a lyon
comme partout en france les rues sont
quasi désertes
le trafic routier tourne au ralenti
conséquence depuis le début du
confinement on respire mieux dans la
capitale des gaules
l'impression est la véritable on respire
beaucoup mieux
mais surtout plus que la pollution
c'est le silence le fait qu'ils aient
plus de circulation en ville
on fait attention le rhône qui coule je
l'avais jamais entendu j'ai constaté
qu'on respire mieux et ça sent moins
mauvaise les particules on les voit pas
alors qu'habituellement à lyon vous avez
c'est toujours voile et là vous avez
aucun voile y compris sur l'eau y
compris dans le paysage donc la qualité
de l'air mois depuis 12 ans j'habite à
lyon j'ai jamais vu ça c'est très
agréable
simple illusion ou real à mes lioration
l'atmo associations de surveillance de
la qualité de l'air montrent une
réduction radicale de la pollution à la
zot liée principalement au gaz émis par
les voitures
revers de la médaille la baisse modérée
de l'émission de particules fines
nocives pour la santé
un phénomène lié à la consommation plus
importante de chauffage en cette période
mais qui pourrait diminuer avec
l'apparition des beaux jours on peut
observer des baisses jusqu'à 10% en
proximité automobile mais par contre on
peut également observer une élévation
sur des quartiers résidentiels qui qui
se chauffe au bois puisque le chauffage
au bois
concernant les particules est le
principal est le principal émetteur de
particules dans l'atmosphère et donc ça
montre que pour améliorer la qualité
l'air bien sûr il choisir sur toutes les
sources puisque agir sur le trafic me
suffit pas puisque là on voit que au
niveau des particules on est plutôt sur
une baisse qui est plutôt plutôt très
modéré
si le confinement a donc permis de faire
reculer l'épidémie de couronnes à virus
il a également réussi à rendre l'air de
nos villes plus respirable